à
bonsoir à tous deux invités ce soir dans
preuve par 3 dans le cadre bien sûr de
la campagne des élections législatives
dans une vingtaine de minutes c'est
florian philippot porte parole du
rassemblement bleu marine est candidat
lui même du front national en moselle
qui sera avec nous et tout de suite nous
accueillons robert rochefort député
européen et vice-président du modem
bonsoir soir merci d'être avec nous et
avec moi perrine tarneaud de public
sénat
et puis pierre ou keep you lie de l'
agence france-presse qui succédera
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure andrea bambino
spécialiste du front national à la fp
robert rochefort comme françois bayrou
vous avez voter françois hollande au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que donc aujourd'hui vous ne
souhaitez pas une copie cohabitation
vous espérer une victoire du parti
socialiste peut être complète absolue ou
pas dans la perspective d'une alliance
demain tout cas j'espère déjà à court
terme que françois bayrou sera
l'assemblée nationale d'accord c'est une
des questions importantes et je vais me
rendant je vous dis je vous dis que s'il
y avait une majorité socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale et que la voix de
françois bayrou ne soient pas entendus
eh bien je ne serai pas très content de
ce résultat là avec les conséquences
politiques alors oui ou non il n'y a pas
dit a pas de constructeur boucherait
l'avenir non c'est pas ça que ça veut
dire
alors ça veut dire qu'il ya deux choses
il ya la vie des partis des
organisations et puis l avis de la
démocratie et si notre pays était
démocratie complètement accompli la
question ne se poserait même pas c'est à
dire s'il y avait le minimum de dose de
proportionnelle que les démocraties
modernes comme l'allemagne ont autour de
nous et bien il y aurait pour la
formation politique que nous
représentons avec pour faire simple le
score qu'a fait françois bayrou élection
présidentielle nous aurions une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de députés de
façon naturelle
ce n'est pas le cas et je trouve à cet
égard que la démocratie française n'est
pas complète et je dis très simplement
que les électeurs de pyrénées
atlantiques les électeurs de pau tout ce
qui contribue à cela ont certainement en
tout cas dimanche prochain et le
dimanche suivant à faire une petite
correction par rapport à cette
imperfection de la démocratie très bien
alors nous allons revenir encore 2
c'est une interview bien sûr sur l'enjeu
majeur pour vous et pour l'avenir du
pays sinon vous suite de cette élection
dans le béarn et perrine oui pressé sur
françois bayrou robert rochefort il a
été reçu en début de semaine à l'elysée
par françois hollande
le chef de l'état l'a raccompagnée sur
le perron l'elysée on a vu que françois
hollande lui serrer très longuement la
main sinon plus non plus alors est ce
que ça veut dire que françois bayrou a
reçu des assurances pour conserver sa
circonscription
écoutez je les ai eus au téléphone après
cet entretien mais ne pas dit les choses
en ces termes
néanmoins je crois que c'est pas un
secret d'état que de savoir que au sein
des socialistes il ya deux camps il ya
un camp qui est celui qui souhaite que
françois bayrou soit l'assemblée
nationale et qui était d'ailleurs prêts
à faire le geste qu'il fallait et
françois hollande en faisait partie
avant d'être président de la république
il ya un autre camp qui est probablement
je peux employer des mots trop méchant
mais qui représente la forme politique
un peu traditionnelle à secteur
c'est vous qui le dites c'est vous qui
le dites en tout cas une forme politique
du passé celles qui ne nous permet pas
de faire face aux défis de demain
alors il est clair que j'interprète en
tout cas cette poignée de mains de
françois hollande comme peut-être un
signe envoyé y compris aux électeurs
socialistes du béarn consistant à dire
moi président de la république j'ai
besoin de consolation puisque la france
on en moi mais je parle je fais comme
ouvrez les guillemets vous avez bien
quoi vous devez que françois hollande va
reprendre la main sur martine aubry pour
résumer écoutez je ne vous dis pas les
choses comme ça mais moi je propose
gauche qui pourrait se faire entendre
entre les deux tours des législatives je
voudrais faire autrement une façon
beaucoup de clubs politiques
est ce que vous croyez que françois
hollande a été élue uniquement avec les
voix des militants socialistes des
adhérents socialistes ceux du front de
gauche et ceux des verts évidemment non
si une majorité de gens pour voter pour
françois hollande c'est parce qu'il y
avait dans le pays
beaucoup de gens qui voulaient changer
qui voulait que nicolas sarkozy ne soit
pas réélu ces gens là ne sont pas des
socialistes
il représente une 106
lité qui est une sensibilité qui est
probablement beaucoup plus proche de ce
que en tant que force centrale nous
incarnons alors ils sont pas forcément
tous voté pour françois bayrou parce que
il ya eu cette logique du vote utile qui
a fait qu'ils ont voté pour françois
hollande
mais en tout cas ces gens là et par
respect vis-à-vis de ces gens là oui je
dis qu'il est important que notre
sensibilité soit représentée dans le
lieu finalement sacré dans la démocratie
pas que je le dis sans phrase comment
dire exagéré qu'est le parlement etc l
assemblée nationale hier
est-ce que vous pensez que un éventuel
échec de france à beyrouth et à qui vous
posez mais pas trop prendre cette
hypothèse mais remettre en cause la
politique de la main tendue qui a été à
la gauche initié par le modem alors je
moi je ne fuis pas les questions je ne
fais pas de langue de bois donc je vais
répondre à votre question je pense que
françois bayrou sera réélu mais il est
légitime de se dire peut-être qu'il ne
le sera pas s'il ne l'est pas je vais
vous dire tranquillement que ça changera
pas là comment dire la dynamique dans
laquelle nous sommes ça ne changera pas
non propositions le fait de dire qu' il
n'y a pas de sortie de la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui sans un
élargissement du socle sur lequel
françois hollande s'appuient aujourd'hui
est en fait vous savez je vous parlais
de main tendue je sais pas si c'est une
main tendue c'est pas ça qui a été
c'est un moment donné en toute
conscience
un raisonnement politique qui fait qu'on
dit eh bien c'est pour françois hollande
que nous votons mais ensuite
effectivement parce que nous ne sommes
pas des gens qui voulons une certaine
façon la terre brûlée bien nous disons
que nous ne voulons pas l'échec de
françois hollande
et à partir du moment où une majorité
s'est construite et à partir du moment
où les sujets sont difficiles un jour
viendra je pense d'ailleurs qu'il est
déjà venu mais il faut voir de quelle
façon et par quelles étapes et bien
françois hollande devra s'inspirer d'un
certain nombre de choses les programmes
avec au choix relais s'il est battu donc
et bien le combat se poursuivra
notamment avec lui et toujours pour lui
autour de lui donc finalement même dans
une posture de martyrs vous nous dites
françois bayrou à son destin de
lui non je vous dis je vous dis la chose
suivante attendez attendez attendez
soyons ces robots sont fatigués dans son
entourage
soyons sérieux je vais très bien
rassurez-vous enfin soyons sérieux il y
a cinq ans il y a dix ans françois
bayrou a été élu dans sa circonscription
dans un contexte politique qui n'a rien
à voir avec celui de cette année celui
de cette année c'est le point
d'aboutissement d'un processus
d'indépendance qu'a voulu françois
bayrou et ce processus non il n'y a plus
aucun député modem à la chine allait
bien et bien ce sera en tout cas
l'illustration est la preuve que notre
système de bi polarisation est un
système qui n'assure pas une véritable
démocratie en illustration d'un échec de
françois bayrou
qu'est ce qui serait un échec le fait
qu'ils soient pas élus l'assemblée
nationale écoutez ce serait pas un
succès c'est incontestable mais ça ne
veut pas dire que la proposition
politique qu'il fait ne leur est pas une
chance parce que encore une fois le jour
où il y aura une proportionnelle une
part proportionnelle dans le pays et je
vous rappelle que françois hollande
s'est engagé à cette part de
proportionnelle
et bien il y aurait des députés de notre
courant est évidemment françois bayrou
on remet mais ceci étant dit vous voyez
bien je le dit et on en parle pour
françois bayrou ce soir mais vous voyez
bien que pour d'autres formations
politiques y compris d'autres formations
centristes y compris pour le jean louis
borloo et et ses troupes
on parle beaucoup de rama yade en ce
moment où d'autres vous voyez bien que
d'une certaine façon il y as chez eux la
nécessité d'être alliée à un courant
politique fort en l'occurrence l'ump
pour être élu ceci n'est pas sain ceci
n'est pas bon j'ai l'espoir je pense que
certains des députés ou des ou des
candidats du parti radical du nouveau
centre de l'union centriste de
l'alliance centriste serait capable ou
serait tout à fait prêt à être dans une
logique de plus grande indépendance si
le jeu électoral leur permettait cela
alors nous nous sommes dit certaine
façon on est quoi on est à l'avant garde
un peu des estafettes de cette situation
là on le paye cher
vous avez complètement raison mais je
crois qu'on est dans le vrai dans le
juste très bien la conviction toujours
chevillé au corps espérer peser si vous
n'avez pas d'élus parce que c'est
vraiment le la question sont
fondamentales trouvait à la longue les
attendait au cours des cinq dernières
années il y avait vous l'avez souvent
dit il y avait l'assemblée nationale
trois députés modem
je pense que dimanche prochain
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disent les
instituts de sondage
c'est à peu près ce que l'on nous donne
compte tenu du jeu démocratique est
alors que nous avons accru notre logique
d'indépendance et ben il y aura pas
grand chose de nouveau
ce sera un peu triste parce qu'on n'aura
pas pu faire plus mais on n'aura pas
fait - et pendant cinq ans les 50 qui se
sont écoulées nous avons au contraire pu
avancer des propositions avancées des
idées faire en sorte que je crois nous
avons été entendus et il va de soi que
les trois millions et demi d'électeurs
de françois bayrou d'il ya quelques
semaines ils sont pas sortis de nulle
part ils sont pas quantité négligeable
et ils sont essentielles et stratégiques
encore une fois non pas pour dire
françois bayrou a raison mais pour
sortir le pays de nos différents
rochefort juste une question bizarre qu
est ce que la voix de françois perroux
pèsera de la même manière si elle
il n'a pas le look selon ctions de 2,2
suffrage universel si les pins et lui
est ce que il pourra s'exprimer de la
même manière en tant que simple je
divague président du modem marc de sa
mort politique déjà d'il ya cinq ans
donc je ne sais pas comment il fait pour
annoncer la mort de quelqu'un dont il
avait déjà déclaré la mort il ya cinq
ans il est probablement dans le principe
de réincarnation mais ça le regarde
en tout cas en tout cas en tout cas pour
pour ce qui est de oui je crois qu'il
est important qu'ils soient l'assemblée
nationale c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure et il est important que il ya
une mobilisation pour qu'il y soit et je
vais même vous dire quelque chose de
plus fort encore
je dirais quelque part un peu honte aux
socialistes si jamais il ne l'est pas
mais ceci étant dit si ne l'est pas non
je vous assure que le combat continue
comme on disait dans le temps et puis
vous savez en plus
il ya de nouvelles pratiques politiques
qui apparaissent il ya le fait de mettre
fin au cumul des mandats qui est une
très bonne chose et donc vous allez
aujourd'hui beaucoup de leaders
politiques même pensé à martine aubry ou
penser à alain juppé qui sont des
leaders politiques qui ont comment dire
un avenir personne ne dirait que ces
personnes sont condamnées à se taire et
qu'ils ne seront pas dans l'assemblée
nationale à venir dont je crois que oui
il est possible malgré tout de faire
entendre sa voie d'être un vrai leader
politique nationale même si par un
malheur d'un système électoral incomplet
il n'a pas sa place à l'assemblée si je
veux qu'il y soit honte aux socialistes
s'il n'est pas blessé n'a pas eu si vous
les culpabiliser déjà là avant
l'élection social espace il n'est pas
parce que vous savez très bien que s'il
ne l'est pas soyons clairs qu'est ce qui
va se passer entre le premier et le
second tour
il est vraisemblable que il y aura un
combat entre françois bayrou et puis la
jeune candidate socialiste qui est là
donc
ben voilà ça se jouera alors est ce que
est ce que vraiment il est logique il
est fondé compte tenu de ce qui s'est
passé que ce combat de second tour se
passe comme cela et ce jeu s'il ne
sacrifie pas l'une vu leur nom je ne dis
pas sacrifier d'ailleurs attendez je
vais je vais vous faire une confidence
et chaîne eurosport
j'ai rencontré un certain nombre de
leaders socialistes avant cette élection
qui m'avait dit de toute façon nous ne
mettons pas un candidat leader national
dans sertir seule circonscription et
c'est pas un hasard c'est parce que nous
ne voulons pas m comment dire françois
bayrou en difficulté alors que cette que
c'est que cette candidate ayant comment
dire l'énergie et la fougue de la
jeunesse s'y voit déjà que je respecte
leur fait et vous donc on vous croit
vous avez noté qu' il n'y aucun leader
national du parti socialiste la
circonscription spéciale le président ce
que j'allais sénat jean pierre bel n'est
pas venu chez vous il est allé à côté
chez me fais la salle uniquement et bien
sûr et bien mauvaise et ne croyez pas
bien sûr non c'est pour ça c'est pour ça
que quand je dis honte
vous voyez bien que c'est le point
limite et que je suis convoquée au fond
de moi-même pour n'atteindra pas ce que
nous sommes associés à orange
cours de cette émission également et
avec son application tv tchèque qui vous
permet vous téléspectateurs intervenir
dans l'émission est de poser votre
question n'est ce pas périmé exactement
aux mêmes questions d'antoine s'il ya
des députés modem à l'assemblée
nationale seront ils dans l'opposition
et ce qu'ils voteront la confiance au
gouvernement
alors c'est très simple et je crois
qu'effectivement c'est pas comment dire
immédiat à comprendre en deux phrases
donc j'ai besoin de trois phrases nous
serons ça comment dire l'ensemble des
responsables de ce courant le centre
pour la france dans lequel le modem est
la force principale
nous l'avons dit nous serons à soutenir
toutes les décisions qui seront des
bonnes décisions
et d'ailleurs si vous regardez déjà
comment dire dans les expressions de
françois bayrou il ya un certain nombre
d'expressions qui sont comment dire que
j'allais dire les plus tôt benjamin
robert rochefort bon je vais vous même
la politique du gouvernement
je trouve je trouve par exemple je
trouve par exemple que c'est très bien
de la part du gouvernement et de
françois hollande d'avoir compris que
une mesure coûteuse comme celle du
retour partiel à 60 ans de la retraite
qui aurait pu coûter 5 milliards de
l'avoir arrêté à 3 milliards je trouve
que c'est bien
voilà un message pour ceux qui ont fait
ça restera cinq milieux côtiers ump
disent que veut dire l'ump
moi je crois aux organismes statistiques
ne serait ce que parce qu'à un moment
donné j'en ai dirigé dans ce secteur qui
une fois que marisol touraine est
arrivée aux affaires
on chiffrer cela à 3 milliards et je
pense et nous continuerons à dire que
évidemment françois hollande a des
engagements de campagne est respecté
mais qu'à chaque fois qu'il pourra les
respecter à l'économie plutôt qu'à les
dépenses supplémentaires en france bien
nous serons à ses côtés l'ancien premier
ministre en croatie ont dit que le
gouvernement fait exactement le
contraire de ce qu'exige la crise
aujourd'hui françois fillon se trompent
normes et gélules françois fillon j'ai
lu son interview il ya deux jours dans
un grand quotidien
il dit d'ailleurs des choses
contradictoires puisqu'il dit en même
temps que cette mesure est pour lui
mesure qui ne convient pas du tout et il
dit en même temps si vous avez eu à
tenter dans cette interview que c'est
donc sur cette mesure
la modification de la mesure faite par
les socialistes est finalement une
pichenette et qu'elle ne modifie pas
grand chose à la réforme
donc il faut qu'il choisisse françois
fillon il peut dire l'un ou l'autre mais
il ne peut pas dire les deux à la fois
il vous a pas oublié qu'il est en
campagne électorale à deux niveaux à la
fois dans sa circonscription est pour sa
part et quatre salariés sur cinq
effectivement et bien respecteront
désormais les règles de la réforme
fillon lycée il faut faire les autres
alors qu'à venir quoi mais sur la
question à laquelle vous n'êtes pas ils
m'ont répondu vous même poursuivi
surface défiance
vous le savez le budget fait qu'on ait
ou pas si on le veut tout sur vous
n'êtes pas dans la majorité dans
l'opposition donc c'était des questions
très précises à sion précise sur cette
question précise il est trop tôt pour le
dire
vous voyez bien qu'il va falloir voir
comment le budget va être préparé
en tout état de cause si des six comment
dire un certain nombre de signes
suffisants sont faits par le
gouvernement pour non seulement ne pas
être dans une posture irresponsable
compte tenu des enjeux financiers et moi
je le dis franchement il faudra que le
gouvernement socialiste fin des
économies dans les dépenses publiques
j'ai pas peur de le dire mais si en même
temps de l'autre côté il y à une relance
de la production point thème chaud sur
lequel nous sommes extrêmement mobilisés
vous le savez bien
autour de ce qu'on appelait le produire
en france derrière tout cela
tous les artisans tous les chefs de pme
s'il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
vont dans 700 dans cette boîte direction
pourquoi ne pas ne pas le voter je n'en
sais rien il n'y a pas de tabou en la
matière mais il faudra inventer quelque
chose et peut-être que là aussi il
faudrait réfléchir à ça il faudra
inventer quelque chose qui est peut-être
que l'on peut soutenir quand c'est bien
et en même temps ne pas être un béni oui
oui et en même temps ne pas prendre sa
carte du parti socialiste mais encore
une fois je crois que si françois
hollande parce que ça joue dans les deux
sens si françois hollande fait des pas
dans notre direction
il faudra fondamentalement des pas vers
la vraie majorité qui l'oeil de
l'assemblée je vous pose à nouveau la
question demain quelles que soient les
circonstances
dans sa circonscription et qu'elle sera
pour françois nom de l'interlocuteur
françois bayrou un allié moi je crois
qu'il saura il saura quelqu'un qui fera
tout pour ne pas l'empêcher de réussir
mais qui sera là en lui disant monsieur
le président il ya quand même un certain
nombre d'inflexions par rapport à vos
propositions à faire pour être sûr d'y
arriver dans ces salles vous imaginez un
tandem de jeu vous imaginez un tandem
demain non je veux vous dire les choses
suivantes la réalité quelle est la
réalité
vous avez vu cette semaine il y a eu
encore un rapport de plus celui de
l'inspection générale des finances après
celui de la cour des comptes est ce que
vous savez est ce que vous savez les
gens qui écrivent
est-ce que vous avez que les gens qui
écrivent ça les ports sont les mêmes que
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui les
conseillers de françois hollande
donc je dis simplement agencement
hollande par exemple jean michel charpin
qui est un ami c'est un ancien
statisticien bon mais il y en a d'autres
et pensé par exemple au secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée quel ancien
rapporteur général de la commission
attali et relisez les textes le comité
interne il ya quatre ans vous verrez
donc ce que je dis simplement c'est il
ya encore une forme un peu anciennes de
faire de la politique avec une sorte d'
affichage public qui ne dit pas
complètement la vérité des choses et
puis en arrière des gens réalistes keith
harris des efforts sur tf1 après les
législatives la vérité sera
progressivement dit
après les élections législatives et à
chaque fois qu'il y aura cette vérité à
dire et à faire à transformer dans des
actes eh bien nous serons là et nous
soutiendront cette démarche et nous y
participerons parce que c'est ça dans le
pays aujourd'hui le président de
république le gouvernement sont dans le
flou et le mensonge
ça veut dire que il y à un contexte qui
est encore un peu un contexte électoral
ça vous a pas complètement échappé alors
françois bay on le dit qu'il n'entrerait
pas un gouvernement qui ne souhaitait
pas y entrer c'est est-ce que c'est
aussi votre cas
écoutez que françois bayrou dit ça c'est
logique parce que s'il vous avait dit le
contraire vous auriez tout de suite dit
banco
en revanche est ce que je pense qu'il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait deux ministres
modem au gouvernement non je ne pense
pas cela et d'ailleurs
si vous avez vu attentivement le sondage
la semaine dernière il ya un sondage qui
dit que les français préféreraient des
ministes modem plutôt que des mini ce
front de gauche au sein du gouvernement
ça correspond à cette majorité dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure est donc à partir
du moment où cela se ferait sur un
minimum de reprise des thèmes sur
lesquels comment dire nous sommes et
nous avons fait des choses et des
propositions je vous donne un exemple
arnaud montebourg je suis je trouve que
il démarre de façon dynamique c'est
incontestable il démarre dans un
traitement que j'appellerais un
traitement de de pompier volant en
allant dans toutes les entreprises qui
sont en grande difficulté
c'est très bien nous savons c'est pas
suffisant nous savons qu'il faut une
politique offensive et ça ne passe que
par par exemple la restauration de la
production de la production en france
eh bien à cela pour accompagner et pour
porter ce type de profession politique
oui nous sommes disponibles et je le
suis vous avez été satisfait de la
création de ce ministère du redressement
productif vous en tout cas le mot le mot
le monde ne m'a pas choqué en
particulier parce qu'il montre bien par
rapport à l'ancienne dénomination qu'il
n'y a pas que l'industrie qui compte et
que la réduction la reprendre comment
dire la production et relancer la
production ça veut dire aussi dans les
services
ça veut dire aussi dans l'artisanat et
dans différents types d'autres activités
merci robert rochefort et je retiens
votre formule 1 vous l'avez noté rothau
socialiste si françois bayrou n'est pas
vrai
ces minutes paris les par j'ai utilisé
un conditionnel absolument je me sens
moi il n'était paru absolue florian
philippot du front national va prendre
votre place dans une minute
marine le pen bien sûr entend tirer
avantage de son score présidentielle
pour envoyer des députés à l'assemblée
nationale
mais le mode de scrutin l'abstention et
puis le reflux traditionnel de son
électorat d'une élection l'autre
pourrait compromettre son plan jérôme
rabier 18% des voix à la présidentielle
572 candidats en lice est pourtant bien
que crédité de 14 à 16% des suffrages le
front national n'aura peut-être aucun
élu à l'assemblée nationale la faute à
un scrutin majoritaire à deux tours qui
pénalise les isolements du fn dans ces
conditions marine le pen estime qu'un
seul élu serait déjà une victoire
cinq députés frontistes un triomphe ce
sera une représentation même si on a
qu'un mais ce sera quand même une sorte
de d'image symbolique très forte au sein
de l'assemblée nationale cet élu sera
très médiatisé et du coup avec lui
le front national les meilleures chances
d'entrer à l'assemblée sont aussi les
plus médiatiques pour le rassemblement
bleu marine marine le pen elle-même dans
nord gilbert collard dans le gard où
marion maréchal-le pen petite-fille de
jean-marie candidat dans le vaucluse
il faudra pour cela mobiliser car avec
une abstention estimée à 40% il faudra
obtenir plus de 20% des suffrages pour
se maintenir au second tour
plus le nombre de triangulaires sera
élevée et plus le front national
fragilisera sa cible privilégiée
l'ump si l'ump est en difficulté
électorale on sait très bien que ça va
renforcer le front national c'est la
stratégie du front national de devenir
la force d'appoint indispensable pour la
droite de gouvernement et donc il ya une
sorte de coalition qui aille de l'ump au
front national on en est pas encore là
mais c'est sa stratégie
un bon score du rassemblement bleu
marine permettrait également de
renflouer financièrement à front
national qui avait dû en 2007 se séparer
de son siège et licencié de nombreux
cadres ces législatives avec ou sans
élus devraient donc permettre au fn
d'envisager sereinement l'avenir
voilà florian philippot est avec nous
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous je le
disais donc vous êtes le porte parole de
ce rassemblement bleu marine et vous
êtes vous même candidat aux élections
législatives en mosaïque vous découvrez
le terrain ben je sais ma première
campagne le candidat pour la première
fois je suis le porte parole de moi même
et donc sur le terrain et j'essaie de
d'utiliser de jouer cette double
casquette de porte-parole national il me
fut efficacement que ses vignes où je
vous emmène d'abord dans une autre
circonscription on a donc vers le nord
voilà hénin-beaumont alors il ya de
nouvelles accusations aujourd'hui de
jean-luc mélenchon
après la diffusion sur le net de photos
le montrant en hitler on se demande où
ça va s'arrêter
bah oui je sais pas qui a fait ça mais
c'est pas nous mais c'est un truc qui
circule sur internet c'est ça et il a
put la responsabilité de ces tracks
comment les appeler comme ça même s'il
circule uniquement sur les réseaux
sociaux au front national
bouygues ça peut être n'importe quel
ennemi le front national qui a fait ça
pourquoi pas un militant du front de
gauche d'ailleurs alors plus facile
d'accuser comme ça les autres peut-être
qui perd un peu ses nerfs mais ce
mélenchon
en même temps vous avez vous même sur
hénin beaumont l'ancien faux tracts il
ya une dizaine de jours présentant
mélenchon avec 7,7 appelle à voter pour
lui en français en arabe est ce que vous
avez balancé peut-être une mode est ce
que ça va donner des idées à d'autres
et est ce que sont les méthodes loyal
finalement de campagne c'était un tract
complètement assumé voilà c'était un
tract qui reprenait des propos réel de
jean luc mélenchon ce qu'il avait
vraiment dit il était bien que les biens
que les électeurs sachent ce que 1 des
compétiteurs disent vraiment parce que
c'est un impact politique
ce qu'il dit c'est important alors je
vois qu'il assume pas ben si il faut
qu'ils assument
s'il est pour l'ouverture totale des
frontières on ouvre grand très grand les
vannes de l'immigration il faut le dire
on peut pas d'un côté défendre les
travailleurs français et de l'autre côté
dire qu'on est pour l'immigration
incontrôlée parce que ça c'est le projet
du medef ya là une contradiction que les
électeurs hongrois lettre on peut faire
campagne à la place des autres comme ça
la place de six adversaires décidé d de
la propagande de ses adversaires c'est
un tract pour faire connaître voilà vous
savez marine le pen fait beaucoup de
tracts et son équipe pour faire
connaître son projet ces propositions on
a le droit de faire connaître aussi ce
qui n'a pas été clairement perçu par les
français parce que ça nous semblait
important est la preuve c'est que là bas
à hénin beaumont les français les
électeurs on parle beaucoup
parce que ça les intéresse ils parlent
du fou bien sûr vous n'avez pas
l'impression surtout que les électeurs
les citoyens français perçoivent de
cette campagne à hénin beaumont a
simplement un concours d'insultés entre
les deux candidats est ce que c'est un
exemple de démocratie
ecoutez jean luc mélenchon il est venu
pour ça il a dit moi je débarque là pour
faire je crois un combat homérique
il répond également à lui répond c'est
la moindre des choses à se faire
insulter se fait traîner dans la boue en
permanence mais il a fait ça pendant
toute la campagne présidentielle non non
elle insulte au pas et elle l'a t-il la
traînée pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle dans la boue et
l'insulter la traiter de folle qui
traite ses électeurs de chez pas quoi
poivrot ivrogne ou je sais pas quoi
bah écoutez on peut pas laisser faire ça
ils veulent éradication je crois
politique des électeurs de marine le pen
l'éradication politique ça veut dire
quoi il prend ses responsabilités c'est
lui qui organise le bazar médiatique
il prend ses responsabilités marine le
pen avait fait une campagne de fond elle
va voir les français si elle bat jean
luc mélenchon est ce que l'avenir
politique de jean luc mélenchon est
compromis ben je crois que il avait fixé
un seul objectif pour la présidentielle
s'était pas de faire progresser ses
idées de faire gagner ses idées c'était
de battre marine le pen d'être devant
marine le pen s'est perdue - l'ami 8
points derrière et bien là s'il perd une
nouvelle fois peut-être même qu'il sera
pas au second tour
un peut-être même pas assez souvent aux
phrases politiques pour lui bien sûr et
si elle perd marine le pen si elle perd
ce sera un naufrage pour elle aussi
belle et dans une conception qui est pas
facile c'est ma région de gauche
lg des ambiances mélenchon il a fait
moins grave pour l écouter mélenchon il
a choisi une circonscription facile
voilà c'est une sa position je rappelle
qu'à voter être pour hollande à 60% à la
présidentielle marine le pen n'est pas
sortante
donc c'est elle qui va au charbon celle
qui va au charbon
si elle perd malepère ça sera forcément
très juste mais c'est pas très grave
elle continuera le combat ce sera juste
dommage pour la démocratie parce que
tout de même que quelqu'un qui
représente 6 millions et demi
d'électeurs n'est pas de représentant à
l'assemblée nationale si on considère
que c'est démocratique et républicain
alors je ne suis plus que cet arrêt nous
tracer la rue l'autre on va parler au
cours de cette émission
jean luc mélenchon dimanche et puis
dimanche suivant votre à part
procuration à paris qu'est ce que vous
pensez de sa domiciliation écouter et
oui il n'est pas dit l'a dit moi de
toute façon je vais dans la
circonscription puis je m'en vais voilà
hamiti peut atterrir comme on dit dans
la circonscription quand on est
parachuté on peut être pas un film il
faut bien atterrir il faut y rester il
faut vouloir y creuser son sillon
mais quand on dit d'emblée moi je viens
mais je m'en vais j'en ai pas grand
chose à faire
à écouter les électeurs en tirerons les
conséquences donc vous même vous prenez
l'engagement de vous installer à forbach
les années moi je suis là pour essayer
de redresser la situation du bassin
houiller en moselle parce que depuis que
les mines ont fermé qu'est ce qu'on a
fait qu'est ce qui a fait le député
sortant rien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que pour lutter
contre l'insécurité là bas rien et des
voitures qui brûlaient le député sortant
l'ump me dit oh non il se passe rien on
a eu un débat en s'emmêlant il se passe
rien il n'y a aucun endroit dans la
circonscription ni aucune heure du jour
de la nuit où on est en insécurité
ça a fait rire mais je dirais même
pleuré noir ces constructions tellement
c
c'est tellement décalé des rallyes que
vous sembliez envisagés il ya quelques
instants quelques secondes l'absence de
députés du front national à l'assemblée
nationale 1 est ce que votre objectif
finalement lors de ces législatives
n'est pas d'abord de semer la zizanie à
l'ump non notre objectif c'est de faire
rentrer des députés bleu marine à
l'assemblée nationale pour représenter
nos idées et ce serait quand même je le
rappelle je le redis la moindre des
choses
votre vie stif aujourd'hui mais c'est ça
c'est combien mais combien c'est
difficile de vous dire un chiffre parce
qu'il ya un mode de scrutin absurde et
pas démocratiques qui fait qu'ils
conditionnent l'accès au second tour à
la participation pour faire douze
ennemis les inscrits ou est 2e donc je
suis là je n'ai pas la solution
individuelle serait déjà une belle
victoire oui parce qu on part de zéro
parce qu'un député qui rentrera mais je
pense qu'on peut avoir plusieurs ça
permettra de faire connaître aux
français ce qui s'y passe le faire
connaître les rapports les blacks le
ministre l'éducation nationale est
obligé de publier des dizaines de
rapports qu'avec qui n'avaient pas été
publiés dans son ministère
qu'est ce que c'est que cette politique
nous on fera connaître tout de suite est
friand des propositions que ni l'ump ni
le ps ne sont capables de faire parce
qu'on a un projet radicalement différent
savoureuses ou telle abstention et je
vais peut-être
donnez l'occasion d'approuver la un
appel lancé aujourd'hui par le président
de la république françois hollande en
effet dans l'oise appel à la
mobilisation des électeurs pour lui
donner une majorité est également revenu
sur le premier point qui le rejoignent
les mollets j'aurais aimé qu'il soit un
peu plus haut j'aurais aimé qu'il soit
aussi républicain en recevant marine le
pen à l'elysée alors oui c'était au
prétendu 26 millions et demi d'électeurs
seront enterrés publicité non juste une
question sur la mobilisation est ce qu
une faible mobilisation serait le signe
finalement d'une faible dynamique autour
du chef de l'état autour de françois
hollande
peut-être mais de toute façon sur le
terrain je peux vous dire que ni l'ump
ni le ps ne font vraiment campagne
leur objectif c'est je pense qu'il y ait
un maximum d'abstention
parce que on veut donner la prime au
sortant parce que les sortants au savs
on le sait ont leur clientèle et donc
évidemment leur objectif c'est que les
français n'avaient pas aux urnes mais
nous notre objectif c'est qu'ils aillent
aux urnes qui s'expriment que les
électeurs de marine le pen se dit c'est
très important ces législatives parce
que ça fait changer les choses
au delà de ça on est obligé de discuter
de ces questions de participation parce
qu'il a ce mode de scrutin nous nous
proposons la proportionnelle intégrale
comme ça se fait dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne dans une majorité de
pays parce qu'il faut tous les courants
d'expression puisse être présenté à
l'assemblée nationale ça me paraît être
la démocratie en majorité de pays c'est
des systèmes mixtes qui existent pas la
proportionnelle intégrale le défaut
d'impressionner l'intégrale il n'y a pas
de proportionnelle du tout vous êtes
pour la proportionnelle intégrale le
défaut de ce système dont le sait c'est
qu'il ne permet pas d'avoir des
majorités solides
est ce que vous vous contentez riez d'un
d'une d'une proportionnelle partiel donc
fait je serais déjà ce sera déjà mieux
ce serait déjà mieux mais il faut la
proportionnelle intégrale
parce que les députés sont quand même
capable de se voit là il faut qu'
effectivement et mouiller un peu la
chemise c'est plus compliqué pour eux
effectivement il ya plus de débat parce
que nous on serait là parce que d'autres
courants politiques qui sont pas
représentés serait là aussi
donc effectivement on sortirait du petit
confort douillet entre l'ump et le parti
socialiste ont fait semblant de
s'écharper de mercredi devant les
caméras de télévision mais en réalité on
vote ensemble et même chose qu on est
d'accord
non non ce serait plus compliqué et ce
serait plus encombrant pour je ne
comprends plus fatigant mais ce serait
la démocratie seulement 86 ça s'est bien
passé il y avait la proportionnelle
intégrale entre 86 et 88 ça s'est bien
passé
donc ça peut bien se passer demain je
pense qu'on n'est pas plus bêtes que les
autres parce qu'il ya toujours une liste
noire
front national le candidat de l'ump à
faire disparaître jamais eu de liste
noire donc à part jamais eu dans notre
effectif bleu marine
si on additionne les uns après les
autres nathalie kosciusko morizet jean
françois copé claude guéant et bien des
députés ump à faire battre donc on peut
commencer à parler de liste au bout de
n'y apparaissent pas une liste noire
vous pourriez rajouter et là il est
socialiste monsieur cuche et dames
messieurs toucher la rente pas de calais
dont son collègue dalongeville dit dans
un livre qu'il est manifestement
corrompus vont c'est lui qui le dit on
verra bien mais nous on pense qu'il n'a
rien à faire à l'assemblée nationale
mais là la question se posera pas
puisque notre candidate sera au second
tour non mais c'est vrai qu'il y à des
députés qui ne respectent pas la morale
publique ne respectent pas les règles de
la république
et on se dit qu'ils n'ont rien à faire
effectivement dans une assemblée d'élus
dans la sixième circonscription des
bouches-du-rhône candidat de l'ump s'est
dit favorable à une entente avec le fn
hollande à battre oui roland chassain
pour battre michel vauzelle le candidat
socialiste
comment vous réagissez et est ce que
vous vous êtes prêts à une entente avec
eux c'est à dire à vous désister au cas
où votre candidate ne serait pas ne
serait pas en deuxième position sur ce
cas local pas ça prouve que sur le
terrain il y a des gens qui sont un peu
plus capable d'entendre la base parce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une rupture absolue
entre la base parmi je parle à l'ump
mais aussi d'ailleurs une partie du
parti socialiste entre la base et là les
apparatchiks les élus nationaux les élus
nationaux eux ils sont toujours dans
leur mire agissons toujours à faire
voter socialiste comme il l'avait fait
aux cantonales ils sont toujours dans
leur petite guerre de chefs leur guerre
politicienne le regard de tactiques et
stratégies à la base certains élus comme
ce monsieur se rendre compte que
effectivement les électeurs attendent
autre chose mais moi je dis directement
aux électeurs de l'ump là bas de voter
rassemblement bleu marine ce sera plus
efficace sera plus rapide ce sera
regretté aussi peu difficile quand même
bien sûr que si des premiers tours on a
une très bonne candidate malades l'oxer
faire revenir l son bureau politique
extraordinaire dès lundi d'élan
mende du premier tour des élections
législatives pour répéter c'est jean
claude gaudin a justement élus des
bouches du rhône également qui le dit il
n'y aura pas d'accord pas de perspective
d'accord avec le front national
bah oui on ne veut pas d'accord d'une
saison avec l'om t16 l'ump suit ce
qu'ils font vraiment en politique
d'ailleurs le laxisme l'europe de
bruxelles là ils vont accepter les
eurobonds sur sarkozy disait qu'il était
contre mais simplement parce qu'ils
anticipent et l'opposition dans gala
merkel ils sont pour les plans de
sauvetage de la grèce
les la dette mutualisée ils sont pour le
plan ultra fédéral qu'on nous propose
ils sont pour l'ump comme le parti
socialiste s'il suivi leur ligne
idéologique il devrait quasiment appelé
à voter socialiste ce qui prouve ont la
même politique parce qu'ils pensent la
même chose
voilà voilà ce que c'est que l'ump ça
m'étonne pas ensuite de voir nathalie
kosciusko morizet et d'autres appeler
systématiquement à voter socialiste
contre le front national
c'est logique ils sont dans leur
mentalité bobo bien qu'ils continuent
mais pendant ce temps là aux électeurs
sont en train de fuir il en train de
sont en train de venir chez nous parce
qu'ils savent que nous on incarne la
cohérence
on incarne un camp politique qui est sûr
de ses convictions qui est sûr de ses
choix qu'il n'y ait qu'un chef une
explosion de l'ump si on vous suit dans
votre le jeu explosion de personnes vous
savez les ont pas besoin de nous pour
exposer ils sont déjà en train de mettre
la pagaille au sein de leur parti de
faire leur guerre des chefs
on n'a pas besoin de les aider ils se il
se débrouille très bien tout seul est ce
que au soir du premier tour vous
pourriez appeler à voter socialiste
contre certains candidats de l'ump
d'ailleurs à citer qu'elle eut quelques
noms notamment
oui août et je peux pas vous répondre
sur ce qu'on fera le soir du second tour
parce qu'on ne sait pas où on sera
présent au second tour on verra ça au
cas par cas comme on l'a toujours dit il
est évident que de référence majorité
jusqu'à quand la très grande majorité
des cas on l'a déjà dit on ne pourra pas
choisir entre ump et ps
mais dans tous les cas on pourra se
maintenir au second tour
systématiquement on se maintiendra
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
maintenant d'accord s'il ya des députés
du rassemblement bleu marine à
l'assemblée nationale théâtre / est
votre première initiative votre première
proposition de loi par exemple
écoutez moi je crois qu'on mettra le
débat européen sur la table là on nous
annonce pour fin juin
un nouveau plan ultra fédéral je le
disais on nous annonce les punition
automatique
on nous annonce la mise en place d'un
président de l'europe
on nous annonce une série de mesures de
dette mutualisée on doit payer on va
devoir payer notre dette mais aussi la
dette des autres
les euro bond ben non s'opposera ça on
proposera par exemple on proposera par
exemple concernant les protections
économique et social la mise en place de
barrières douanières par une proposera
la mise en place de barrières douanières
d'utiliser la france officiellement un
sos la dans les heures peut-être dans
les jours qui viennent puisque son
système bancaire connaît une déroute
totale
vous pensez qu'il ne ferait pas que la
solidarité européenne joue pour
préserver l'économie de toute la zone
euro enfin écoutez ça fait quand même ça
fait maintenant plusieurs années qu'on
le dit ça nous dit et solidarité
solidarité
sortez le chéquier fait un chèque pour
un nouveau pays elles deux fois la grèce
déjà bientôt 3 l'irlande le portugal
maintenant l'espagne entre 40 et 80
milliards d'euros nous dit le fmi et la
france et 20% de co2 par donc ça fait
quand même entre 8 et 16 milliards rien
pour la france d'alourdissement de sa
propre dette encore mais ça va continuer
jusqu'à quand quand est ce qu'on va se
dire ça marche pas on n'est pas dans la
bonne voie c'est ce que nous disons
depuis des mois et des mois on nous a
dit dans la crise est réglée c'est
terminé puis sur le cas spécifique de
l'espagne je serais quand même signaler
que tout ça pour ça alors l'europe
depuis les années 80 depuis que
l'espagne est rentré dans la cee l'union
européenne
on a fait des chèques on a financé les
fonds structurels combien de paysans
français ont été sacrifiés pour les
paysans espagnol combien d'argent qui
n'est pas venu en france pour aller
financer des routes en espagne et
aujourd'hui on arrive à cette situation
j ai oublié du coup chaque pays doit se
débrouiller du coup chaque pays doit
peut-être se débrouiller effectivement
mais il faut surtout changer les règles
parce que sinon chaque pays aucun pays
ne s'en sortira pas ce qu aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on vit on dit on vous donne
un chèque mais en contrepartie c'est les
plans d'austérité effroyable comment le
reste mais c'est pas une c'est pas
humain ça d'un côté vous ne voulez pas
des plans d'austérité mêlant donc au
bourg et de la solidarité européenne à
notre nation comme aux autres nations
d'europe
c'est un changement de modèle pour
protéger chacun et pour redresser toutes
les situations pour aider l'ensemble des
peuples européens
alors il faut le protectionnisme parce
qu'il faut que ce continent se
réindustrialiser c'est dans les gènes de
l'europe d'avoir de l'industrie c'est
dans son adn
on a des très bons travailleurs en
france et en europe ben oui il faut pas
renoncer
faut pas se dire que tout va partir
forcément en chine non
réindustrialiser ce continent on peut
rien y serez les à la france mais il
faut changer de modèle économique on met
des protections aux frontières
il faut se dire que cet euro là c'est
pas un succès manifestement on essaie de
le sauver de faire des plans de
sauvetage de dépenser des centaines de
milliards d'euros pour sauver une
monnaie qui a fait beaucoup de mal à
notre économie et qui n'est pas viable
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire demain on
attend d'explosion comme ça on attend on
paye on attend et puis se passe rien que
sur l'annoncé si ça explose ça se fera
dans le chaos nous on veut préparer les
choses or ils attendent sur les futurs
débats l'assemblée nationale daniel cohn
bendit il souhaite que le futur groupe
écologiste à l'assemblée déposent une
proposition mois vers une dépénalisation
du cannabis est ce que le sujet mérite
débat selon vous enfin écoutez moi je
crois qu'il ya déjà un des sujets plus
importants et plus urgents
la question de l'emploi je le disais la
sécurité 1 10 ans de dégradation de
sécurité sous juppé
et là on envoie des signaux de laxisme
en corse où la gauche des questions très
importantes l'europe je le disais sur le
cannabis
bah oui qu'est ce que vous voulez ça
m'étonne pas de daniel cohn bendit 1 ces
retours à cette espèce de mode ou les
ministres vont nous dire les uns après
les autres avec la plus grande fierté
que eux aussi ont fumé un joint quand il
était jeune
parce qu'on va revenir à cette époque
comme à l'école au ministre de
l'éducation nationale on nous annonce la
suppression des notes
oui c'est l'esprit de mai 68 qui imbibe
et déjà la politique de l'ump mais
maintenant ça assume et on le dit dans
le discours c'est la même politique mais
maintenant c'est assumer une question
des contres évidemment la dépénalisation
du cannabis
on veut renforcer et on veut mettre en
place une véritable lutte contre la
drogue parce que c'est un fléau moi
quand j'ai appris que les jeunes
français étaient les premiers
consommateurs de drogue en europe c'est
une enquête qui est sorti je crois la
semaine dernière moi j'étais effondré
j'étais effondrée et j'espère qu'on
pourra enfin se donner les moyens de
lutte et de renforcer la lutte contre
les consommateurs et contre les dealers
parce qu'on a strictement rien fait on a
baissé les bras contre la drogue depuis
des années dans notre pays et ça c'est
pas digne une question maintenant avec
notre partenaire orange et l'application
tivi tchèque une question 2 pire henry
la normalité de françois hollande est
elle normale
bon on avait pendant cinq ans le bling
bling
une collusion totale avec les puissances
d'argent c'était extrêmement fatigant
maintenant on a une normalité surjouée
une simplicité ostentatoire je croise
quelqu'un qui a trouvé ses limites à ce
dialogue avis à une simplicité
ostentatoire c'est là qu'on veut montrer
qu'on est simple à settat bon non plus
c'est à dire que maintenant les
ministres doit se prend le rer et ça il
ya des limites aussi attention nous ne
tombons pas non plus dans la démagogie
ne tombe pas dans la démagogie
voilà ça part d'un bon principe quand
même sur le fond rompre avec le bling
bling oui faire des économies sur le
train de vie des ministres de l'état
très bien oui mais par exemple sur le
salaire du président de la république
un exemple sarkozy arrive il a multiplié
par trois et là on le baisse de 30%
ben oui mais l'addition c'est qu'on
revient pas la situation antérieure
parce qu'on en fait un peu exagéré je
crois à six questions
non non c'est plus 204% donc c'est même
un peu plus que par trois en fait foi 3
-30% babur vous êtes toujours beaucoup
plus haut qu'avant ça aurait été mieux
de suivre notre proposition c'est notre
proposition c'était pour tous les
ministres pour le président république
pour le premier ministre le même salaire
que les parties comptent quelque chose
qui vous plaisent dans le nouveau
pouvoir là quand vous regardez
l'alternance depuis quelques semaines
non j'avoue que en cherchant bien on est
vraiment ne me surprend en même temps je
n'attendais pas grand-chose de françois
hollande c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
oui j'étais au départ j'étais assez
heureux de la décision de retrait
d'afghanistan
et puis ensuite on a appris qu'en
réalité ça concernait que quelques une
partie 60% je crois des effectifs
présents là-bas et qu'en réalité les
autres resteront donc là aussi on nous a
pas dit tout à fait la vérité gisti
raisons logistiques et ont amené le
matériel oui mais il ya toujours des
bonnes raisons on a toujours de bonnes
raisons de ne pas faire les choses on
peut pas déserté comme ça du jour au
lendemain
il faut partir le plus tôt possible
parce que ça fait dix ans qu'on est
embourbé là bas ça fait dix ans qu'on
voit nos fils mourir moi j'aimerais
qu'on parte plus vite possible
on arrête d'ergoter cette semaine vous
avez lors d'une conférence de presse
annoncée que si le front national était
à l'assemblée nationale il y aurait une
proposition de loi sur les mariages
brillant alors en quoi ça consiste
qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans cette fois
finalement concrètement alors ça parle
effectivement là c'est mariage très
bruyant et même dangereux que les
français maintenant connaissent bien
parce qu'ils les subissent vous savez
ces voitures qui passent à 120
kilomètres dans les rues dans les rues
qui roulent sur les trottoirs qui
arborent des drapeaux étrangers ça crie
partout etc
il ya une des coups de feu la forme bac
où je suis le maire a essayé de mettre
en place une charte à une charte c'est
un bout de papier c'est pas que c'est
pas contraignant ça me rappel vous savez
ce que l'on faisait pour le voile à
l'école
au départ durer quoi dans cette loi va
passer une loi qui interdit ces
débordements qui fait respecter le code
de la route ont interdit ces
débordements s'est pas appliqué s'est
appliqué puis je vois pas pourquoi on
arbore des drapeaux étrangers lors de
ces mariages vraiment moi je trouve
qu'il faut pour l'interdiction des
drapeaux étrangers lors des mariages je
pense qu'ils ont rien à faire avec les
interdire lors des manifestations
publiques en général mais je pense que
c'est un symbole lors être que le
mariage c'est aussi un symbole
républicain et je trouve qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on se limite aux
symboles républicains ça me paraît être
de bon aloi moi quand j'ai vu l'élection
de françois hollande et la bastille avec
tous ces drapeaux et qu'il fallait
chercher tout ça c'est comme le jeu où
est charlie on cherche le drapeau
français
on l'a pas trouvée et bac en jeu quand
j'ai vu ça j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
triste moi j'aimerais qu'il ait un peu
plus de drapeau français
alors oui ça me rappelle vous savez
cette situation ça me rappelle le voile
à l'école ont laissé les chefs
d'établissement seul faisait des chartes
mais ça servait à rien un jour il a
fallu faire une loi pour appliquer la
loi de la république
c'est ce qu'on propose pour ses mariages
bruyant et dangereux parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'accidents parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de nuisances et qu'il faut
mettre fin à cette dérive
merci philippe aubert
nous voir aujourd'hui donc alors que
vous êtes en pleine campagne je le
rappelle en moselle merci à vous merci
andré à murcie perrine bonsoir à tous